on sait leur tout de suite de notre
second débat pour une fois on reste dans
l'actualité du jour avec le sommet de
l'océan et vient de s'ouvrir à brest une
vingtaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement attendus et pour emmanuel
macron une nouvelle occasion de
s'afficher en défenseur de la planète
mario dépêche le sommet s'est ouvert sur
la musique traditionnelle du bagad de
lann bihoué groupe de la marine
nationale française lors d'une rapide
prise de parole l'envoyé spécial de
l'onu pour les océans est revenu sur
l'importance de signer un traité
juridiquement contraignant pour
sauvegarder la biodiversité de la haute
mer un trésor
fragilisé par les activités humaines
il ne peut y avoir de planète saine sans
océans en bonne santé et le déclin de la
santé de l'océan se mesurent 2022 est
l'année où on peut stopper ce déclin ce
traité porte sur plusieurs domaines
comme le souligne la sénatrice du
finistère qui accueillera dès demain une
délégation sénatoriale ça permet en fait
tous être au même niveau d'information
avec différentes conférences qui
permettent de mettre en lumière en fait
toutes les tout ce qui se déroule au
niveau des océans à la fois sur le fait
que ce soit tour et du tourisme qu'on
puisse se développer du tourisme mais
c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle de
l'économie bleus c'est à la fois des
transports donc tout est mis en lumière
et le but du sommet pouvoir se mettre
d'accord sur
comment on protège les eaux
internationales notamment qui sont les
eaux qui se sont à 370 km de nos côtes
comme le sénateur de la polynésie
française rappelle également le rôle
essentiel que doit jouer la france dont
la protection des océans je crois que
c'est l'occasion
votre sommeil à la fois de participer
peut-être réveil de la conscience
maritime française parce que je crois
qu'elle s'est un peu endormi
et en tout cas tout le monde n'a pas
conscience de la l'étendue maritime que
représente la france aujourd'hui avec
ces outre-mer
c'est 11 millions de kilomètres carrés
c'est énorme ça fait quand même
le domaine d'ô même mondiales mais 97 %
de ce domaine et dans les outre-mers
donc tu viens aussi pour rappeler la
nécessité un simplement de cassettes
rentabilité mais aussi de se donner les
moyens à la fois la surveillance la
protection
et d une meilleure connaissance de notre
et deux de nozay 2 dans tous les océans
vendredi une vingtaine de chefs d'état
et de gouvernement mais aussi les
dirigeants des géants du transport
européens se réuniront autour du
président français plusieurs
associations dont france nature
environnement compte par ailleurs
remettre aux responsables français et
européens une pétition contre les
captures accidentelles de dauphins au
large des côtes françaises les enjeux de
ce sommet de l'océan que peut-on en
attendre
on en parle tout de suite avec marina
lévy bonsoir soit bienvenue vous êtes
océanographes directrice de recherche au
cnrs directrice adjointe du département
océans et climat de l'institut de
recherche pour le développement
frédéric dans les bons soirs
journalistes spécialisés questions
environnementales vont publier ensemble
pour mieux se nourrir enquête sur les
projets solidaires et durables pour
sortir de la précarité alimentaire c'est
chez actes sud
cyril coutançais bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
directeur de recherche au centre
d'études stratégiques de la marine vous
publiez la relocalisation du monde j'ai
pas votre éditeur sendrès ses tresses
édition merci beaucoup voilà comme ça on
est prêt si matthieu croissandeau
toujours à mes côtés évidemment et avec
non duplex en visio conférence romain
troublé qui est directeur général de la
fondation tara océans bonsoir romain
troublé vous êtes ambassadeur de ce one
man show mythe alors justement je
commence avec vous vous êtes à brest
pour que vous avez accepté cette mission
quel rôle vous vous pensé jouer puis
pourquoi ça vous semble important
écoutez pour nous qui défendons les
linges de l'océan et de la recherche et
de la connaissance et la protection des
océans depuis maintenant presque avec la
fondation tara quand on voit des
semaines comme ça qu'ils n'arrivent pas
tous les quatre matins où des chefs
d'état se mobilisent pour parler
politique sur fond de l'océan bah on est
là pour essayer de soutenir et pour
aussi partagé français ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on voit aussi avec les scientifiques
à bord des différentes missions qui sont
menées à travers le monde je reviendrai
avoué évidemment régulièrement pendant
ce débat frédéric dans les vous vous
définissez comment ce sommet c'est quoi
pour vous cette cet objet là bon on va
essayer d'être gentil basse et une
liturgie laïque comme on aime bien en
avoir il ya eu glasgow donc on fait des
grands gestes ont fait on désigne des
coupables on se réunit on se parle c'est
très bien les gens se parlent c'est une
grande foire aux associations c'est
parfait mais n'en sortira rien parce que
la france est un pays de marins la
france est pas un pin maritime
parce que la mer à peu près tout le
monde s'en fout donc c'est moi moi
j'aime beaucoup soufflé tard assez
remarquable ce que fait ta je ne sais
pas ce que tu as he a fait la passe que
font rien en attendre on va on va
effectivement on aura
l'information va passer mais enfin s'il
faut que les chefs d'état se réunissent
alors que les scientifiques notamment à
brest à plouzané un sens scientifique
extraordinaire ya un labo extraordinaire
qui s'appelle le lait mars a fait des
années que les infos parce que madame
travaille là dessus il faudrait que tout
d'un coup les politiques se réunissent à
brest enfin la fois les la wii la fois
les lames et jusqu'à jusqu'à présent on
était plutôt à un niveau technique
effectivement
marine and heavy donc là on passe au
cran politique c'est ce qu'on peut en
espérer en tout cas de ce sommet oui
tout à fait je pense que l'info et les
là effectivement depuis longtemps ça
fait longtemps que les scientifiques
alertent sur les les méfaits du
changement climatique en particulier sur
les océans et aujourd'hui voilà c'est
l'occasion c'est comme le premier sommet
sur les océans c'est quand même
l'occasion d'en parler
encore et encore et moi j'en attends
j'en attends beaucoup moi j'attends
j'attends que des mesures que parce que
j'en attends beaucoup parce que
parce que le pire n'est pas n'est pas à
venir ou laisser serment parce qu'on
peut encore agir et que et que tant
qu'on peut agir il faut continuer à
parler et qu'il faut continuer à faire
des sommets et je pense que c'est
important de dire dans quelle mesure on
peut encore agir et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
encore changer et pourquoi on peut
encore le changer et ça et ça je trouve
que c'est important et je trouve qu'un
deuxième enjeu c'est l'enjeu d'inégalité
entre les pays c'est à dire et on le
sait et on le répète et ça fait
effectivement 20 ans qu'on répète mais
c'est les pays du nord qui créent les
dégradations et pour les océans c'est
comme pour le climat c'est les pays du
sud etc les pays les plus pauvres qui en
subissent le plus et pourquoi parce que
si le
la température des océans au monde de 1
ou 2 degrés qu'est-ce que ça provoque
pour leur procès en principe aux
habitants c'est à dire les poissons ils
vont ils vont migrer c'est ça alors si
on augmente la température de 1 ou 2
degrés se passe énormément de choses
dans les océans les poissons
effectivement vont migrer vers le nord
ils vont migrer vers des températures
qui sont plus clémentes pour eux il va y
avoir aussi un effet de perte d'oxygène
l'océan va perdre de son oxygène et donc
les les poissons vont s'éloigner de ces
zones qui ont pas d'oxygène parce qu'ils
ont besoin d'oxygène pour respirer et
tout ça ça se passe aux latitudes
tropicales donc on va avoir
des pêcheurs norvégiens qui vont trouver
dans leurs filets des poissons qui
viennent des tropiques et au contraire
les les poissons et les zones tropicales
elles elles vont elles vont subir les
conséquences on voit les pêcheries de
crevettes sur les côtes indiennes il ya
des faillites qui sont liées aux pertes
d'oxygène on voit en inde les stocks de
crevettes les femmes qui pêchent les
crevettes dans le sine saloum au sénégal
elles ont vu leurs stocks divisé par
quatre en dix ans évidemment déjà liée
au réchauffement ça c'est lié aux
émissions de gaz à effet serre oui on va
continuer d'en parler je reviens quand
même à l'enjeu politique de ce sommet
donc je rappelle 41 pays représentés
18 chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
centaines d'experts des entreprises
aussi privé de l'entreprise de transport
mais mes séries de coutances et il
manque la chine et la russie n'était pas
rien voix c'est pas rien surtout que
l'important dans ces sommets en fait
c'est de mettre l'accent sur des
conventions internationales qui
pourraient changer la dynamique en cours
dans les océans il ya des des grands
sujets par exemple le sujet de la
surpêche on a un accord qui est en
négociations depuis à peu près une
quinzaine d'années au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce pour
arrêter les subventions à la pêche abbas
est typiquement le genre d'accord qui
vous refais qu'il faudrait faire avancer
on a un accord sur la protection de la
biodiversité en haute mer qui est par
ailleurs en négociations allaient onu
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années et
pour ça pour les faire adopter
alors il ya un coup de projecteur qui
est mis avec ce sommet de brest et
pourrait faire adopter ils font un
consensus dans la coban delà de la
communauté internationale donc il faut
que la chine soit d'accord que la russie
soit d'accord et il faut que l'ensemble
de ces pays soient d'accord pour faire
avancer pour qu'on ait une chance
effectivement de faire changer les
choses romain troublé je reviens vers
vous parce que vous avez entendu le
voilà les les critiques exprimées dans
et où effectivement les craintes qu'on
peut avoir parce que la chine et la
russie sont sont pas là vous dites quoi
vous dit malgré tout il ya là une
occasion à saisir
espérons qu'ils que les chefs d'état qui
sont là vont un peu faire bouger les
choses notamment sur cette question de
la la haute mer il faut rappeler les
enjeux de ce squale c'est quoi ce qu'on
appelle les eaux internationales en
famille
ouais je fais un mois j'ai cumulé mer
egée cumo si les sommets atteints depuis
quatre années maintenant sous ce sujet
dos et en fait on n'a pas des sujets qui
sont abordés support technique il n'y a
jamais de ministres qui vient discuter
n'y a jamais de chefs d'état qui
s'intéressent à ces sujets donc ya un
vrai sujet comment on remet en avant
dans cet enjeu politique etc etc et la
mer aujourd'hui et vous l'avez rappelé
cette année de l'immeuble diable
énormément déchéance qui ceux qui vont
se dérouler il n'a peu près quatre ou
cinq même sur l'année
comment mobiliser autour d'eux c'est
l'enjeu de l'océan un groupe de pays un
gros de paix qu'ils disent à l'onu nous
on veut en être on veut aller se
déplacer on veut des engagements
ambitieux et ça c'est des choses comme
brest est une opportunité pour sc2
fédérer des gens autour de ça bien sûr
que leur semaine ça va sortir la boîte
est de la boîte la baguette magique qui
va pas attendre de ce sommet des
résultats des décisions fautes en deux
semaines dynamique et c'est là dessus
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
suis venu ici pour essayer de soutenir
cette dynamique vers des ambitions plus
forte sur les nageuses d'accord de
l'année et
sur la haute mer qu'elle juste pour bien
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
un espèce de un espace pardon de
non-droit on dit on peut dire ça d'une
certaine façon sur la haute mer c'était
une zone qui représente quasiment la
moitié de la surface du globe qui est à
plus de 370 km des côtes de n'importe
quel pays de la planète n'a pas quel
type de la planète et cette autre mère
aujourd'hui elle est pas réglementé mais
dans le monde en jeu de trafic de trafic
dans le trafic de stupéfiants de trafic
d'armes de pollution aussi on peut pas
il ya très très peu de textes en fait
qui permettent aux marines de la date du
internationale d' arraisonner les
bateaux quand il trop y voit des délits
ne délivre ce n'est pas défini donc et
encore tout à définir pour pour ça mais
après on quand on dit ça on dit est ce
que le politique s'est suffi non on voit
bien qu'à la coop climat par exemple la
politique ça fait ça n'avance pas très
vite n'empêche que la sur l'océan la
même pas la politique est déjà là on est
vraiment à la traîne et donc il ya
encore beaucoup de chemin
un focus quand même sur le
l'enjeu alors là pardon je reviens un
peu oui un peu un peu cocardier un peu
tricolore mais il ya un enjeu pour
emmanuel macron quand même voilà il va
il lancé le sommet on est en précampagne
pour lui
présidentielle il peaufine sa stature
internationale c'est le différencie de
ses camps des ses concurrents enfin bon
il ya tout ça quoi oui est d'autant
qu'en plus il a un curieux bilan sur
l'environnement mm macro le plus tôt
plus fait aucun cas la présidence de
françois hollande plus c'est même que
celui de nicolas sarkozy et pourtant par
certains décisions par certains actes il
est jugé anti écolo ou traître ou
hypocrite sur cette question
il ya probablement on a eu peu d'impact
sur la politique intérieure à attendre
de ceux de ce sommet a par l'idée
d'avoir pendant que les candidats se
battre lui qui joue sans le président et
de chef d'état à l'international après
moi j'ai quand même un bémol par rapport
à ce que vous disiez parce que je suis
pas du tout à spécialiser la question et
je pense que ces grands-messes même si
elle ne débouche pas sur des engagements
précis elle permettrait même une forme
de sensibilisation dans l'opinion
publique et on sait que petit à petit
elle est comme ça alors après c'est
peut-être trop pointu mais le climat est
devenu une question d'opinion puis une
question de génération c'est pas que du
climat sain non mais j'ai à occire en
raison des grand-messes aussi en raison
des délais en fin on part de loin moi
j'ai coutume de dire que depuis louis
saez napoléon iii aucun dirigeant
français s'intéressent à la mer enfin
qui c'est en france que la france à la
deuxième zone économique exclusive du
monde qui sait que la france est le seul
pays présents sur tous les océans donc
une responsabilité sur les récifs
coralliens qui sait qu'en france 80 % de
marchandises importées arrivent par
bateau qui sait qu'en france on un des
plus gros réseau de station biologique
d'études la cinquième flotte d'études
scientifiques au monde la france est la
deuxième puissance maritime de par
toutes ces données et tout le monde s'en
fout alors même que cadre encore une
fois ça devrait être un atout majeur et
c'est un atout majeur on voit bien si
les russes et les chinois sont pas là il
ya un intérêt géopolitique les chinois
pendant que nous on a l'on a le regard
tourné sur l'ukraine les chinois ils
vont planter des drapeaux sur le moindre
îlots pour étendre leur territoire par
l'extension des zones de pêche et les
russes font exactement la même chose
pourquoi parce que prévoit le coup
d'après du changement climatique
l'ouverture du passage du nord-ouest
c'est à dire la fonte des glaces en
hiver qui permettrait de récupérer 30 %
du récit de porte conteneurs et des
transporteurs de gaz naturel liquéfié
dont il aurait le contrôle vu qu'il
serait quasiment le seul pays avec le
canada à pouvoir contrôler tout ça et
nous on regarde ailleurs et nous rien
d'ailleurs face et c'est fascinant c'est
facile on n'est pas pin marin olympique
pays c'est ça je comprends pas parce que
vous l'avez dit deuxième espace maritime
au monde ça représente plus de 10
millions de kilomètres carrés aussi sur
sur tous les océans et malgré tout net
on n'est pas un pays de marins nom du
pape sy non mais un pays de paysans les
anglais sont des marins les américains
sont des marins nous on n'est pas un pin
marrant on ne sait jamais tourné vers la
mer cyril et d'expression
on est un pays en fait tant au niveau
des gouvernants je pense qu'on n'a pas
des gouvernants marin alors
effectivement emmanuel macron 1 re créer
un ministère de la mer bon pour
permettre donner une visibilité mais en
fait on est un pays de marins aussi
c'est à dire que sur le littoral on a
des marins ce qui est paradoxal la
chaîne pays c'est une dans notre pays
c'est qu'on a des acteurs dans
l'économie maritime qui sont très
puissants cma-cgm par exemple qu'il 3e
armateur de porte conteneurs au monde on
pose des câbles sous-marins enfin on a
des acteurs qui sont très puissants dans
le domaine de la recherche on a en a des
acteurs qui sont on en parlait tout à
l'heure mais la sorbonne par exemple au
niveau du classement de shanghaï et
troisième mondial dans les os de
l'océanographie ccc quelle légitimité
on a une légitimité parce que on a la
tête du de la deuxième est devenu monde
est en fait du premier espace maritime
du monde parce qu'avec les citoyens d
extension du plateau continental donc on
a une légitimité et surtout de
responsabilité et puis là je voulais
dire qu'on était quand même marin faut
pas oublier tous nos territoires
d'outre-mer et oui parce que là là là il
ya notre espace maritime il vient des
autres maires la biodiversité la plus
riche et bien d autres maires et ce sont
des peuples à wallis et futuna en
polynésie et c'est qu'ils sont des pubs
de marins ils ont écrit toute une
histoire extraordinaire mais je retiens
la somalie zigouzis moyal il ya aussi un
autre enjeu de ce sommet c'est justement
l'éducation à l'océan jeudi on est un
pays où la surface maritime est
importante et on n'apprend pas l'océan à
l'école et ça c'est un des enjeux c'est
c'est d'apprendre le fonctionnement de
l'océan parce que mon ne peut le
défendre que quand on a compris un petit
peu comment ça fonctionne et on fait de
l'histoire ont fait de la géographie ont
fait des maths ont fait pas de
scénographe doit-on me fais plus
beaucoup c'est vrai c'est un enjeu de
cette campagne là c'est reparti mais je
suis d'accord avec vous d'ailleurs
l'intérêt de ce sommet c'est que nous
médias on est en train de faire un débat
de 40 minutes là dessus et je fais aussi
un peu de pédagogie par exemple je
donnais le chiffre sur les l'espace
maritime français 23% des eaux protégées
ça veut dire quoi ça quand on dit des
eaux protégées alors les eaux protégées
ça veut dire que c'est des eaux où on va
essayer de faire en sorte que les
écosystèmes ne soit pas affectée par les
activités humaines donc on va éviter de
faire des pêches de protéger etc on a
prouvé que c'était c'était efficace
c'est à dire que effectivement quand on
protéger certaines régions ça permettait
une restauration des écosystèmes
donc c'est ça les eaux protégées
d'accord romain troublé c'est aussi un
enjeu de ce sommet de de brest ce qu' il
était temps des houles des zones
protégées c'est ça
bien sûr oui il y a cette année en chine
justement de répondre à ce mec les
sommets de la biodiversité de la
diversité biologique la cdb qui a lieu à
kunming c'est par contre au camp mais
qui qui devrait elle se met d'accord m
l'état d'accord sur une protection de
balle planète océan de 30 % en 2030
c'est la target mais les chinois surtout
à présent à bord de cette idée après qui
dit protection dit quelle protection à
quel niveau de protection tout n'est pas
tout n'est pas forcément très efficace
et c'est là le tout et le la vie dans le
gabardan et détails
sur ce sommet en fait je pense que pour
que vos téléspectateurs comprennent
l'océan il a affecté par deux types
d'activités il ya les activités humaines
terrestre d'une certaine manière
réchauffement climatique c'est ça ça se
fait à terre beaucoup et puis la
pollution plastique ont réduit sous
plastique etc mais après et c'est
peut-être l'intérêt de ce sommet c'est
que quand vous disiez que la haute mer
était par exemple peut réguler elle est
surtout alors c'est réguler parce qu on
a une convention des nations unies celle
du droit de la mer qui doit réguler mais
sauf qu'elle n'a pas prévu toute une
série d'activités est en fait l'océan
supportent de plus en plus d'activités
humaines on peut rentrer longtemps on a
eu la pêche le transport maritime
maintenant on a la pause de quatre
sous-marins on a des champs d'éoliennes
on a des champs pétroliers gaziers et
ces deux actions minières ou alors il ya
la question des leviers on est c pour ca
qu
cccr marines protégées justement qui
étaient évoquées sont importantes parce
que cette explosion d'activités humaines
fait qu' il ya une série d'impacts
justement pour la diversité marine qui
est très importante est de plus en plus
importante le bruit etc il ya des tas de
choses et donc il faut avoir des
mutuelles entre guillemets pour
ça il faut pas oublier que même si on a
ces sanctuaires ça va de pair avec avec
le changement climatique et à mesure et
que et bien que les mêmes si on arrange
est tous les autres problèmes simplement
avec le changement climatique on
affecterait l'ensemble des écosystèmes
dans les océans justement du fait du
réchauffement du fait de la
signification alors c'est quoi la
signification encore et encore un peu de
chaleur l'acidification c'est le fait
que l'os est en fait nous a protégés un
petit peu du changement climatique en
absorbant un quart des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de co2 et ce gaz et en
acide quand il est dans l'océan et le
rend plus acide et donc on observe une
acidification des eaux ce qui va faire
que certains organismes vivants certains
de coquillages
certains organismes qui ont des
squelettes calcaire des huîtres voilà
les cours aux locaux royaux de corail
aussi elle n'arrive pas à vivre dans ces
eaux plus acide donc ça affecte les
écosystèmes alors l'année est vraiment
spectaculaire dépassez pas anecdotique
surtout le réchauffement où on voit les
massifs de coraux et du blanchiment des
coraux et ça c'est vraiment complètement
livre on
insiste vraiment là-dessus parce que
c'est à l'échelle planétaire je vous
rassure pitre pêche avec ce ce chiffre
donné par l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture deux espèces de poissons
sur trois qui sont
surexploités frédéric dans et est ce que
il faut et peut-être surtout est-ce
qu'on peut interdire certaines formes de
pêche en bas c'est déjà le cas il ya des
pêches c'était le cas pour le thon rouge
vous savez on a crié haro sur le thon
rouge les pêcheurs c'est pas bien il
pêche melba mine de rien on a fait
appliquer parce que nous pays riches
avons les moyens de faire appliquer les
quotas on est on les a obligés à on a
obligé les pêcheurs les thoniers aa
a signalé lors d'ébats leur débarquement
on les a obligés à prendre des
observateurs notamment beaucoup de
scientifiques de l'ifremer sur les
bateaux et résultat aujourd'hui le temps
aux portelais en méditerranée
l'océan il a cette capacité de son cas
très peu de saison irait on vous l'avait
dit moi je les ai vus j'ai plongé
pendant 15 ans partout dans le monde
vous vous interdisez simplement la pêche
sur une région pendant un an ou 18 mois
ça s'appelle un cantonnement de pêche
par exemple étaient trois drapeaux et
vous dites aux pêcheurs souvent ils
décident eux mêmes vous arrêtez de
pêcher et et les choses reviennent déjà
si vite ah oui ça va vite ça va vite les
poissons sont là tranquille et ils se
reproduisent et puis quand y'en a trop
ils s'en vont hisser meilleur c'est ce
qui a fait le succès de l'acceptabilité
sociale du parc naturel du parc national
de port-cros parce qu'ils ont joué sur
les pêcheurs les pêcheurs départ allait
en disant on veut chasser du mérou non
vous ne passerez pas de mes roues mais
puisque vous chassez pas de mai ont
regardé dans dix ans ils vont grossir la
autour de port cros est présideront
ailleurs et là vous les vendre et plus
cher parce qu'ils seront plus gros et ça
a marché
j'ai perdu le fil du temps la pêche
ou pas ça c'est générale en europe
globalement les choses vont mieux et en
france encore mieux sur la façade
atlantique c'est à dire que par rapport
à il ya 20 ans aujourd'hui à peu près
60% des stocks de poissons qui vont à
peu près bien céder 25% il ya vingt ans
sur la façade atlantique sur la façade
méditerranéenne c'est la catastrophe là
il ya peu près 90% des stocks de
poissons qui vont mal encore une fois
c'est une question de volonté des états
à contrôler et de la même façon pour les
aires marines protégées on peut faire un
rond autour des terres australes et
antarctiques françaises en dix ans est
protégé mais oui mais quand vous avez
une protection sur 200 milles nautiques
va avoir une marine de hyères qui a les
moyens d'intervenir ce qui a fait
coteaux des terres australes et
antarctiques françaises parce que la
bagna bâtiment de la marine nationale et
un satellite est dévolue à ça la pêche à
la légine est devenue la légine la
légine pardon c'est un poisson tout
moche qui aillent dans les avis qui
aimait beaucoup les américains et les
chinois est prise et ils sont remontés
les niayes grc un mot grâce à vous et
une espèce de la roma d'emblée je revois
je suis content que tu reviens je
reviens vers vous romain parce que vous
vous disiez ans et on s'est vu dans
d'autres émissions auparavant sur une
autre chaîne bismarck pour pour ne pas
la nommer que c'était un enjeu de
société en fait là le fait de réguler la
pêche oui c'est un choix de société
je crois que j'ai bien sûr le protège
pas l'océan parce qu'il est joli et que
les animaux sont en dessous sont beaux
et on protège que l'esp on en a besoin
en fait en a besoin pour l'écosystème
pour respirer pour stocker le carbone on
en a déjà parlé aujourd'hui et on a
aussi besoin pour se nourrir et les
enjeux de protection sont pas contre la
pêche ils sont pas garanties on me l'a
déjà dit frédéric une pêche une pêche
qui va continuer à produire je veux
continuer à être à partir un gagne-pain
des pêcheurs autour de la planète et
c'est pour ça qu'on doit protéger des
coeurs de pas très lentement on peut
leur propre aux torrents puissent pêcher
et c'est en train d'être compris pas mal
de pêcheurs dans le monde entier mais
j'ai encore beaucoup de travail pour
prier pour atteindre la masse critique
passé de coton c'est ce qu'on vous pose
une question qui tue le sentez vous
sembler totalement idiote mais est ce
qu'on mange trop de poissons en france
et en europe on n'avance pas mal mais
surtout
qu'il faut voir lycée en dynamique ces
affaires-là est en fait le l'évolution
qu'on voit depuis 15-20 ans et qu'en
fait au fur et à mesure que les pays se
développe notamment les pays en
développement des pays en développement
chine etc ils mangent beaucoup plus de
poissons et donc en fait on est il ya
une demande de poisson qui est beaucoup
plus importante mais là ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que c'est un poisson là
on n'a pas toujours conscience parce
qu'on à l'image du vieux loup de mer qui
part sur son chalutier terrain mais
c'est que la majeure partie du poisson
qui est consommé dans le monde
aujourd'hui est élevé il n'est pas pêché
dans le cadre de gigantesques fermes
aquacoles et c'est un des problèmes
d'ailleurs qui ex pas c'est une des
raisons qui explique aussi la surpêche
puisque empêche un quart des poissons
dans le monde aujourd'hui pour nourrir
ses élevages donc on est dit sur des
modèles sont alors là c'est vraiment
l'absurdité complète
par exemple via des systèmes on a quoi
pony et des
cd faire ou c hors sol qu'on n'est même
pas on n'est même pas dans l'habitation
d'une source d'ailleurs j'ai appris ça
de revenus complémentaires pour des
agriculteurs qui imaginent installés
dans des hangars dont ils se servent
plus des des fermes pour par exemple
élevé détruite mais qui sont et qui sont
au démarrage le problème c'est qu'il
faut raisonner glossées ans à couvre
laquelle la quasi totalité du globe il
faut raisonner à l'échelle du globe
c'est à dire que ce conte ce qu'on voit
se développer effectivement c'est ce qui
était évoqué tout à l'heure la pêche
globalement dans les européennes s'est
plutôt améliorée un les stocks et autres
mais c'est à l'échelle mondiale il faut
voir ça et à l'échelle mondiale c'est
pas bon parce qu'effectivement il ya une
demande de pêche supplémentaires il y a
de la surpêche qui assure et enfin en
asie on en a on en a beaucoup et puis on
a des bateaux asiatiques qui vont large
des côtes africaines
si bien que les pêcheurs artisanaux au
sénégal et autres n'ont plus de deux
prises à faire donc on peut avoir des
choses qui s'améliore dans nos pays en
europe mais il faut il faut élargir
notre focale et voir que sur l'ensemble
du club c'est pas forcément fabuleux
d'accord et puis si on mange trop de
poissons et qu'on peut plus manger de
viande rouge on a tous de passer au tofu
je voudrais vous entendre peut-être sur
la moi je suis pas anti pêcheurs loin de
là mais la pêche au chalut qu'est-ce que
ça qu'est ce que ça représente
marina lévy bp pourquoi elle est
critiquée aujourd'hui ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer sacha passive ou si c'est
à vous qu'il faut poser dès fêter la
question qui se pose aux côtés de cyril
sous-tend ça c'est quoi ça détruit le
fond des jeux
salué chez lui ce qu'on reproche au
chalut seller chalut de fond au fait
qu'ils vont aller chercher
vous imaginez une gigantesque hertz de
laboureurs qui a derrière un tracteur
une sous forme d'un filet métallique
voilà avec la gueule grande ouverte qui
fait kiffer 10 15 20 m de large et qui
va racler le fond donc il va tout
prendre ça détruit tout quoi ça détruit
tout par contre le chalut comptes il
émis en pleine mer pour pêcher des bancs
de poissons compact ceylan choix c'est
le maquereau c'est la sardine n'y a pas
de dégâts donc il ya chalut et salue le
problème c'est qu'on assimile tout à ça
du coup on se met à dos les pêcheurs
mais le chalut de fond sur certains
milieux
très pauvre en fait qu'il faut voir que
là ça dépend comment on utilise ça
dépend comment l'utiliser et là on
utilise le problème du chalut de fond
c'est qu'il est utilisé en europe là où
les poissons se trouvent notamment les
morues et là où les mots russes se
trouvent c'est sur des espèces d'oiseaux
au fond de la mer des récifs coralliens
d'eau froide le problème c'est qu'une
fois que vous passez le chalut certes
vous avez pris les meures une vous avez
pris l'endroit aussi où elles se sont
reproduites dont elles reviendront pas
voilà et ça faudrait interdire romain
troublé est-ce que ça fait partie des
enjeux du sommeil effectivement est-ce
que c'est pas interdire le salut c'est
interdire certaines formes de pêche au
chalut alors c'est pas un enjeu du
sommet quelques il est discuté
aujourd'hui dans les ateliers ici on
parle pas beaucoup de techniques de
pêche en parle plus davantage de zones à
protéger de 2,2 voilà je suis d'accord
et vous que si on détruit l'habitat en
fait on détruit l'écosystème et ce qui
reviendra jamais en fait et donc c'est
là le problème c'est ce que dit vanek
c'est que c'est qu'il faut essayer de
freiner ou alors de nature et les
chaluts la gravière où ça affecte pas
ces écosystèmes là et les maîtres de
journée mme endroit donc c'est pas un
gros chat est un gros un gros impact sur
l'écosystème à les deux éléments dans ce
débat des critiques qui visent le
président français vous allez voir ça va
nous amener à une autre thématique
d'abord c'est greenpeace qui évidemment
publié qui sera présente peut-être on va
dire en marge de ce sommet à brest on a
choisi un un tweet regarder un énième
numéro de claquettes d' emmanuel macron
je cite un évidement de greenpeace
france avec un détournement de la fiche
de dons de plo cap pour parler de déni
océanique et puis un son de cloche assez
similaire chez l'ancien directeur des
campagnes de greenpeace france qui est
devenu candidat europe ecologie les
verts à cette présidentielle c'est
yannick jadot on écoute quand je vois
que la france n'a même pas signer le
moratoire sur l'exploitation et
l'exploration des fonds marins
on voit que la logique du président de
la république c'est de faire décider
sommet c'est toujours de les appeler
avec des démons anglais d'ailleurs cemex
de planètes du white eagles en fait on
sait pas si ça reste vraiment français
quand ils s'occupent d'écologie ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il n'agit pas personne
n'est là sur ce plateau pour défendre le
bilan du quinquennat macron sur la
défense de l'eau sert donc on va pas
rentrer dans en revanche ça m'ouvre une
thématique cyril coutançais c'est cette
histoire d'exploration d'exploitation
des fonds marins c'est quoi on y cherche
quels types de minerais et de métaux
déjà faut distinguer deux choses parce
que
riec jadot englober les deux
explorations et exploitations en fait
sur les fonds marins on a des ressources
minérales donc des métaux en gros pour
faire simple
et donc effectivement c'est une vieille
lune parce que ça existait déjà dans les
années 70 on imagine aller cueillir des
va récupérer des nodules polymétalliques
etc vous faites très cher en force
surtout les techniques étaient pas
opérationnel
mais on a une autorité de l'onu une
agence un l'autorité internationale des
fonds marins qui gère cette ces fonds et
donc après il ya deux sujets il ya
l'exploration qui est d'aller voir
d'aller cartographier ces zones donc pas
d'exploiter et ça je pense que c'est
intéressant parce que on a besoin on ne
connaît pas ses fondements de toute
façon on en connaît très peu donc
d'acquérir les connaissances de voir
comment la vie se développe comment
comment elle comment elles existent ça
c'est important donc de ce point de vue
la recherche est importante après
l'exploitation effectivement on peut
mettre de mabel là dessus c'est que de
toute façon ça aura un impact semble
sain sur les écosystèmes et puis surtout
je
m'interroge mois sur le modèle
économique de cette affaire là c'est à
dire que les métaux on en a la terre on
en a beaucoup
il ya encore beaucoup de mines on peut
en trouver encore beaucoup et puis on a
des réserves de métaux qui sont en train
d'être exploité de parts de plus en plus
d'acteurs économiques c'est via le
recyclage en france télécom 1 orange va
retirer le laisser fils de cuivre son
réseau de cuivre par exemple en france
sas et des métaux qui sont disponibles
sont assez facile c'est plus simple de
les récupérer et les recycler plutôt que
d'aller chercher au fond des mers
d'accord mais
est ce qu'on parle aussi des métaux
rares qui sert notamment à fabriquer
tous nos outils informatiques là
potentiellement on n'en manquera sur
terre il va peut-être falloir aller
chercher un an on va donc pas son
expression en fait les les ressources
existent après la question c'est
c'est alors il ya des oppositions
cantons vont ouvrir des mines sur des
métaux rares etc mais les ressources
existent on en a encore pour des siècles
et après c est ce qu on a un équilibre
économique quand on quand on exploite
ses ressources mais on n'a pas de
problème de ressources en tout cas à
terme une exploitation défendu face à
date moi je me souviens le premier
numéro de sciences et avenir que j'ai
acheté j'avais 13 ans la couverture
c'était l'ifremer va trouver les mesures
donc on a 40 ans pendant peut-être
encore le temps on verra bien les les
océans couvrent 70% de la terre il faut
peut-être rappeler ce voilà c'est un
faux de base c'est pour ça qu'on parle
de planète bleue l'un des effets du
réchauffement climatique c'est la hausse
du niveau de la mer écoutez ce qu'en dit
notre ambassadeur des pôles olivier
poivre d'arvor
si nous ne faisons rien
pas dans un siècle dans dix ans
600 millions de personnes auront les
pieds dans l'eau si nous ne faisons rien
dans 80 ans en 2100 les prévisions du
giec sur l'élévation du niveau de la mer
qui sonde à mettre 10 seront la bête 50
pardon seront largement dépassés on sera
à plus de deux mètres et là ce sera de 3
milliards d'habitants qui seront
vraiment submergé donc il ya une urgence
marina les vives et je vais un peu être
franco franco centrer mais il ya des
villes françaises qui sont effectivement
menacé à court terme par cette montée
des eaux disons que ce qui est ce qui
est ce qu il faut savoir là dessus je
vais pas me concentrer sur le cas de la
france mais ce qui est intéressant par
rapport à ce qui vient dire parce que
c'est ça le point vraiment laid c'est
c'est que le la montée du niveau de la
mer ça dépend du taux de réchauffement
et ce tous de réchauffement ça dépend
des quantités de gaz à effet de serre
qu'on va continuer à émettre et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose sur lequel on
peut pas revenir en arrière mais par
contre vraiment ce qu'on peut faire et
j'insiste là dessus c'est qu'on peut
limiter la montée du niveau de la mer et
que ce qui va compter c'est pas
tellement le niveau moyen de montée du
niveau de la mer alors d'accord ça va
peut-être dans certains cas
faire déborder bon on peut se protéger
avec des digues etc mais surtout quand
tu es des tempêtes des choses comme ça
ça peut faire des inondations qui
peuvent être qu'ils peuvent être bien
bien plus
dévastatrices si le niveau de la mer
augmente et ça c'est des choses sur
lesquelles on a moyen d'agir aujourd'hui
pour que dans cinquante ans dans son
temps s'assoit pas comment en limitant
notre
notre consommation de carbone et nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
exactement ça oui c'est exactement ça et
ça les scientifiques sont en mesure de
vous dire de combien il faut limiter et
c'est tous les travaux du giec qui ont
été mis en lumière par le giec c'est de
combien est-ce qu'il faut limiter les
émissions de carbone pour arriver à
limiter l'augmentation de
niveau de la mer alors après pour le
détail des villes françaises il ya deux
exemples biarritz par exemple j'étais à
noël biarritz il ya des panneaux partout
qui vous alerte sur un risque de
submersion poule et ont porté par une
vague ça c'est bien connu et bien risque
d'érosion donc ça c'est naturel mais
s'est considérablement aggravée par la
hausse du niveau de la mer qui rend la
mer plus agressive on va dire le casino
de biarritz dans dix ans il est plus là
il est déjà protégées par des sacs de
sable gigantesque je vois pas comment ça
pourrait tenir encore pendant dix ans un
autre exemple dunkerque entre dunkerque
et une vie qui s'appelle saint-omer il
ya un triangle qui s'appelle les
wateringues c'est une zone qui était
gagnée sur lost un polder au xiiie
siècle c'est une zone qui n'est hors
d'eau que parce qu'à des pompes qui
refoule l'eau de mer et l'eau de pluie
il ya plus d'eau de pluie il ya plus
olmert donc cette zone des 200 milles
habitants c'est une zone maraîchère ne
dépend que la bonne santé des pompes et
là par exemple et plus il ya plus
d'argent pour les pompes il manque 600
mille euros pour que les pompes continue
à fonctionner voilà une conséquence
concrète de la montée du niveau de la
mer une conséquence concrète de
l'augmentation
des abats d'eau dé la pluviométrie à
cause du changement climatique c'est pas
moi je pense aux pays bas les pays bas
prix sandwiches partie des pays-bas nos
vies je sais mais vont être rayés de la
carte alors il serait bien c'est
effectivement mais surtout il y a
on a nos territoires d'outre-mer qui
sont très touchées puis par un deuxième
effet dû du réchauffement climatique
sont les phénomènes climatiques extrêmes
on en a vu on en a vu
une illustration avec irma dans les
antilles à saint martin à saint
barthélemy ça a eu des conséquences
dévastatrices tait et on en aura plus de
nouveaux et ça pour les territoires
d'outre-mer c'est quand même une
problématique qui est immédiate qui est
majeure et ça romain troublé c'est
évidemment un enjeu planétaire où on
parle de 40 pays représentés 10 18 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ils viennent
vraiment deux des cinq continents d'un
peu partout
oui un peu moins d'asie qu'ailleurs mais
il ya des pays aidés notamment des
maires de villes submersible comme lagos
qui vont être là qui qui viennent qui
sont représentés et qui eux se posent la
question de comment s'adapter qui va
payer l'adaptation de ces villes de
demain à la montée de la mer créé la
valette l'impact social parce qu'en fait
qu'on va relocaliser des quartiers
entiers des gens qu'on véhicule à son
nez là où ils sont nés ou alors dire
vous allez changer d'endroit et votre
peau de chez vous savez d'ailleurs
comment on va gérer tout ça c'est une
question qu'il faut commencer à se poser
maintenant parce que ça va être quoi
mettre bien 40 ans à trouver des
solutions
on est loin des enjeux c'est de soi même
et on est vraiment dans le dans le
concret de d'aujourd'hui et des
prochaines décennies ali nous reste 5
minutes pour parler de du plastique 13
millions de tonnes de plastique qui se
retrouve devant dans les océans c'est la
notion ce mythe qui donne ces chiffres
voilà dans l'est dans les documents de
préparation du du sommet là encore un
peu de pédagogie marina billy on parle
souvent du 7e consid continent de
plastique c'est vraiment
réunies en un seul lieu de quoi on parle
en fait y en a on parle d'abord les
sources de plastique à il faut sort que
le plastique vient essentiellement de
déroger part par la terre c'est pas
c'est pas les bateaux c'est vraiment
du plastique il ya différentes formes de
plastique il ya ce qu'on appelle les
maquereaux plastique les bouteilles etc
et puis il ya plein de micro plastiques
qu'on voit pas ne serait-ce que quand on
lave notre linge et voilà les fibres
synthétiques qui passent dans les eaux
usées et qui vont voilà alors en
fonction de la taille des plastiques on
va les micro plastiques ils vont ils
vont être répandu partout dans les
océans ils vont être dispersées et puis
les maquereaux plastique ils vont avoir
tendance à et on va les voir se
concentrer au centre des grands jir
océanique et donc on voit maintenant on
peut les voir par par avion voit très
bien des concentrations qui en a un seul
continent c'est l'émulation le septième
continent africain il y en a plusieurs
il ya plusieurs j'irai on les voit on
arrive à cartographier vraiment
maintenant des concentrations plus
élevées de maquereaux plastique au
centre des gir par contre les micro
plastiques là c'est beaucoup plus
complexe il y en a dans toutes les
profondeurs vraiment on en retrouve dans
toute la colonne d'eau on les retrouve
s'est ingérée par les poissons ces
microplastiques on le retrouve dans les
intestins des poissons et là on n'arrive
pas très bien un des enjeux
scientifiques c'est qu'on n'arrive pas
très bien à suivre en fait toute cette
quantité de plastique on on a on a un
plastique manquant si vous voulez on
n'arrive pas encore à savoir ce qu'il
est ce qu'il est devenu et donc il ya
des recherches pour savoir où et où est
le plastique qui est qu'on a qu'on a mis
dans les océans romain troublé qu au gré
des missions de tara océans vous voyez
cette pollution s'aggraver parce que il
ya aussi moi j'ai souvent discuté avec
des des navigateurs des aventures et des
sportifs qui disent c'est pas partout
visibles comme c'est tellement grand
je pense qu'il ya un rapport de 1 à 10
entre 7,1 me continent placé quand on
parle souvent et le reste l'océan on a
trouvé avec tara du pot nord jusqu'à
l'antarctique des plastiques qui sont
les micro plastiques partout sur la
planète un patou pas tout et c'est
gratuit c'est alarmant et quand
on voit ça qu'on est marin koné
surprendre un bateau qu'on voit ça
qu'est ce qu'on se dit aussi mais c'est
pas ici la solution la solution était à
terre il faut arrêter acheter et c'est
là où il faut agir et c'est pour ça que
les enjeux du de l'océan sont toujours
le sociétaux parce qu'en fait tout cas
de quoi on parle on parle d'économie
circulaire on parle de de mieux capter
nono pollution de plus rejetée dans la
nature on parle de mettre moins sur le
marché de réduire à l'état c'est là que
c'est là que les langes comme les doigts
avec par exemple on a lu en france que
peuvent aussi apporter des solutions
parce que ça oblige les entreprises à se
lancer évidemment massivement dans
l'économie circulaire free ride drive
termine avec vous allez nous reste une
petite minute peut être sur une autre un
peu plus positive vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure mais mais si on laisse
souffler l'océan il a une capacité à se
régénérer oui mais même une marée noire
s'était étudié à brest d'ailleurs à
plouzané c'est par michel glémarec je me
souviens hifti lycée le modèle de
substitution il avait travaillé sur la
burqa disent ils ont créé un modèle donc
le modèle de substitution qui montre que
si après une marée noire aux fous la
paix l'écosystème pendant huit ans tout
est revenu à peu près c'est le à peu
près qui compte ce que c'est c'est ce à
peu près qui peut créer un effet de
bascule si ensuite il ya une nouvelle
marée noire donc même en cas de marée
noire
l'écosystème marin a une capacité
phénoménale à à se renouveler et moi je
les ai vus partout vous foutez la paix
aux poissons vous foutez la paix aux
milieux marins
ben moi je vous invite si un jour vous
avez l'occasion vous allez à cerbère
banyuls voilà il ya une réserve
intégrale qui dépend du muséum alesis un
des plus beaux endroits que j'ai vu au
monde c'est une c'est un peu la
méditerranée comme s'ils avaient pas les
hommes c'est tout petit ça fait 110
hectares c'est une merveille et autour
vous avez les pêcheurs espagnols qui
sont très contents bon merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat romain troublé bon sommet de
l'océan à brest fric dans et donc votre
livre c'est ensemble pour mieux se
nourrir c'est chez actes sud et cyril
coutançais la relocalisation du monde au
cnrs éditions merci beaucoup encore une
fois d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis merci monsieur demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et